Signs that you're actually in a healthy relationship
things that you may have not considered
these are all things that you should have in your partner
and if you don't
then maybe they're not the right one for you
Signs your actually in a healthy relationship starting off with
number one
you can communicate with each other openly and freely
And honestly talk about problems
needs, desires, difficult topics, concerns
You’re basically able to listen to each other
No 2. you respect each other
you see each other as equal individuals
you both value each other's feelings
opinions and needs
You never demean or belittle each other
No. 3 both respect each other's boundaries together or apart
there's no pressure
guilt or cohersion for intimate time or anything else uncomfortable
No. 4 Equality and reciprocation
you both hold each other to the same standards
and both contribute to the relationship
You’re both content with the distribution of responsibility and expectations
It should be a fair give and take for the most part
No.5 Curiosity and Novelty
You should always be interested in your partner's
thoughts, feelings, beliefs, daily life and plans
And you plan or try to do new things together
these are all signs that you're in a healthy relationship
and if you're lacking some of these qualities in your relationship
then you can always work to improve these areas
or maybe that person isn't for you.